やっぱり新卒採用をもしあの時に踏み切ら
なかったとしたら今日のアチーブメントは
100%ありません役立つていうキー
ワードそういう意識が非常に高い人材は
やっぱり新卒の中に支出として含まれてん
ですよ青木サの人生経営哲学100回聞い
たら豊かになる
話今回はですねま中小企業は新卒採用に
取り組むべきかどうかということについて
でまあの実際アチーブメントがまどんな
タイミングでどうやって新卒作用を
スタートさせたのかということについても
含めてですねあのお話しいただきたいと
思い
[音楽]
ますま結論から言えば深層採用できればし
た方が良いと思いますただま
アチーブメントは
1987年10月12日に創業しまそして
2004年から新卒採用に取り組みました
え4大卒の新卒のこう1人ま選択理論をね
え学んでいる中間というかそういう1つの
学びの中からえその学生と出会ってまそれ
まで1人も4大卒新造性取ったことが
なかったのででま彼にアチーブメントに
入らないかとでま大学院に行きたいと本人
言ってたのでじゃあアチーブメントで働き
ながら大学院に行ってももいいよと
やっぱり大学院でプロジェクト
マネージメント学ぶっていうことなので
それは会社にとってもいいことだしあぜひ
っていうことでで彼を採用しましたその子
が優秀だったんだよねうん一言で言えば
新卒採用の責任者にその子を抜擢して考え
さしたんですよで学生視点でえどうやっ
たらその新卒が取れるだろうかでま彼が
最初考えて新卒採用してですね当時
2005年ですけども社員がまだ26人の
時に16人採用したんですよなんでそんな
に多くの人を入れれたのかと言われるんだ
けどこれは僕の多分ねキャリアだと思い
ますつまり元々ブリタニカという会社で
セルスマネージャーやってたので若い人を
のには自信があったの
となんだろう25人の組織に16人入って
くるってのはすごいことだと思うんだけど
も法peopの世界ではあるんですよそう
いうことが普通はフルコミの世界なんだ
けどだ人数に対しては免疫があったって
ことだよねそれを固定休で採用したとうん
なんて言うのかな僕もネガティブな思考
って全くなかったねうまくいくとしか思っ
てなかったうんやっぱり会社を発展させ
たいっていうことやなんて言うのかな
やっぱり選択理論を世の中に広めていき
たい研修会社としてま自分内の志しがあっ
たからスタートしたんだけどまそっから
ずっともう20年深層採用してるわけです
よね社員220名え従業員数が255名ま
その組織になってきたんだけれども
やっぱり新卒採用をもしあの時に踏み切ら
なかったとしたらちょうど私が47歳の時
ですあの時にもし僕がやると意思決定し
なかったとしたら今日のアチーブメントは
100%ありません多分どうでしょう
うん450人の研修会社でそこそこの
レベルではあったと
思うま利益は多分2億売上10億利益2億
社員50名まそんなレベルぐらいには
入れ替わり立ち代わりでやってるかもしれ
ないよねでも今のようにま売上56億経常
利益
18億この規模にはなってないですねでも
それは何がポイントかって言うと一言で
言うと優秀な人材を採用したってこと
ですだから支出かける環境かける本人の
選択とこれが私が作った方程式なんだけど
支出っていうのはもう生まれ持ったものっ
てあるんですよ生まれ持ったものとその
成長過程で培ってきたマインドノーハウ
スキルで大学を卒業する時にはある一定の
レベルでコアのものはできてるその中で
できたら100人の中の20人
2割の人間を採用することが大事ですよね
もし願わくはその100人の中の45人の
人間を採用できた方が入れてからの伸び代
が大きいですで優秀な人間って目先の金
じゃなくて長期的本質的客観的なものの
考え方ができるので人生を長期的な視点で
もの考えられるんですよねで目先のお金
じゃなくて自分の命が何に役に立つのかと
かなんだろうどうしたらもっと自分は役に
立つ人間になれるのかとかその役立つて
いうキー
ワードま貢献ですよねそういう意識が非常
に高い人材はやっぱり新卒の中に脂質とし
て含まれてんですよでもやっぱりこう点々
とする中途作用の人間ってもちろん中途
作用の人間の中にも優秀な人ってたくさん
いるんだけれどもよっぽどの縁があるか
よほど専門職採用で技能が必要であると
言って採用してその技能にふさわしい報酬
でギブアテイクでお互いにそこでバランス
が取れるということならあのあるけれども
まうちの会社って平均年齢30歳じゃない
若くて18億の経常力出してる
これすごいことなんですよだからキャリア
積んでったらもっとパフォーマンス出して
きますからだから平均年齢は常に若い人
採用し続けていくので平均年齢はずっと
若いまま会社の規模が大きくなっていくと
思うんだけれども中途採用の人間でどうな
んだろうこの選択理論を世の中に広めて不
満足な人間関係が禁するあらゆる不幸を
撲滅しようなんて思う人は1000人に
1人いるかいないかじゃないのいや本当だ
から今回うちあの警察官中途採用の人が
刑事までやってる27歳が入社してきたよ
ね殺人現場とかいろんな現場に行って事後
対応では解決しない
となぜこんな不幸な現象が起こったのか
とその元にあるものやっぱ不満足な人間
関係が禁するその人間関係の葛藤だとか
その問題
行動を通して自分が得ようとしていた欲求
をもっと効果的な方法で欲求を満たす方法
をトレーニングする仕事の方に価値があ
るって言って警察感やめてうちに入ってき
たじゃんこんな人ね何年に1人ですよいや
本当に滅多にいないいや宝だよね本当に
そういう意味ではでもそういう人ってのは
中途採用できても上に上がってきますなぜ
ならミッションで入ってきてるから
コミッションで入ってきてないのよだから
コミッションのコとってミッションに
生きるとでもほとんどはコミッションで
言うと報酬をもっと上げたくて転職をする
基本的にやっぱり新卒の方が僕はいいと
思ってるですよただ新卒の場合は育てるの
に育成力がないと測線力人材にならないの
で普通はアチメントって人材育成の専門
会社なので測線力にできるんだよねで今
うちは初任休が新卒で2024年でも
30万来年から33万になるわけですよね
僕はやっぱり人に価値を置いてるんですよ
人なんですようんやっぱり人作りは組織
作り組織作りは国作りだから支出の高い
人間をいかに採用できるかこれがやっぱり
勝敗を分けるんですよでも支出の高い人間
はもう早ければ大学時代にもうゼミの先生
からの紹介で就職先が決まったり例えばさ
お寿司屋さんのネタでもそうなんだけど
築地の大賞
はにてるところになかなかあの手に入ら
ないような美味しいネタを分けてくれてで
もフックスでねあのネタ送ってもらってる
ような寿司屋なんてろなネタ入ってないの
よいや極端に言うと同じだよこれだから元
に上がんなきゃいけないの採用はでもそう
するとやっぱり理念共感型採用ということ
になってくわけだよねだから新卒採用と
いうのは僕はすごく価値があると思います
でもうちも賞味15年ぐらいかかったのか
な深層採用をやれるようになるまではだ
その時やっぱり利益も56億の売上で経常
利益がやっぱり2億近く利益が出てこの
ままだと逆に儲かるということはなん
だろう空気が今までは苦労してたけれども
もう楽になった時にこの楽になる空気に
なるのは良くないと思って先行投資って
いうことで採用始めたんですよだから健全
な負荷をずっと企業の中に作り続けてきた
経営だからま幹部の人たちには感謝して
ます常に自分の目の前の職務責任以外に
プラスアルファで深層作用を全車採用なの
で手伝ってくれてきたのでだから幹部の人
がそういう風にやりましょうと経営者と
一致団結してうちも深層採用しましょうと
いう空気を作れた時が採用のタイミングか
もしれないけどまずは経営者の決断だろう
ね決断とその下した決断に全責任を取る
これがやっぱりリーダーの条件だと思うん
で経営者はそこが腹がくれれば採用に
踏み切ったらいいんじゃないかと思います
そうねまず社内の整備をしなきゃだめだわ
やっぱりその人を育てることの意味や価値
や深層採用に取り組みたいんだけどみんな
どう思うというところからやっぱりこう
環境整備だよね受け皿をしっかりするって
いうことそれとやっぱり何のために今深層
採用をするのかっていうことと深層採用し
始めた時にどんなこう負荷がかかりかつ
問題が起こるのかも事前に予想しながら
対策を考えながらやっぱりしっかりと予算
を取って1人大体200万ぐらいはかかり
ますからね普通はそれぐらいの覚悟を決め
てあとはま最初は合同説明会みたいな
ところを使ったりして情報を得たりし
ながら実際新卒採用で成功してる同業者の
社長からも話を聞いたり情報収集を
しっかりしていくことでしょうねで中を
固めてそれから採用に踏み切るその順番を
間違うとあの深層採用コンサルタントなん
とな安易に入れちゃったらそっちに
ばっかりお金かかっちゃって逆に取れない
からもっと増額みたいになってろなことが
ないうんうちみたいな会社ってのはうち
ほら受性のの採用しかお手伝いしないじゃ
ないそれなぜかって言うと経営者自身が
社員に対する愛情とか会社をこういう会社
に将来していきたいんだというビジョン
エンロールができるような経営者じゃない
といい採用ができないという風に思ってる
から安易に深層採用のお手伝いしないん
ですよやっぱり傾斜教育やって上で幹部
教育やった上でそっから採用に入るとそう
いうのが私はお手伝いしているま1つの
ステップですよねまこのYouTubeを
見ていただいた経営者の方もね参考にして
いただければと思いますはいえ是非ねあの
チャンネル登録お願いしたいですしまた
コメント欄に是非コメントの方もよろしく
お願いします